hey everyone we are back at the
blockchain economic forum we are now at
ovav Goldstein how are you thank you for
coming out to the show thank you very
much appreciate so we you are the chief
marketing officer yes
of feel my network a firmer Network so
this was interesting you were just
teaching me a little bit about this and
so building the infrastructure for the
crypto economy and the especially for
things like derivatives or contracts for
derivatives and other financial assets
that is correct what we've built is a
language a formally verified language
that enables the creation of derivatives
and other financial instruments for
instance swaps futures hedging all types
of financial instrument that are very
very common in the fiat world in the
real world what we call but they pretty
much don't exist in the spirit world and
for a healthy economy it it it's very
crucial so that they would exist in
order that people would be able to trade
with those type of instruments so this
is why we built it there is a very
strong need for those solutions what
does it look like to have a derivative
in fiat currency versus a derivative and
cryptocurrency is there a difference
well let's take a moment to speak about
what a derivative is all about to do it
a derivative means that you can hedge
your holding or investment in any
business and in a way that enables you
to invest in what's really crucial for
your investment so one of the examples
that we like to use infamous we take the
example of an ice cream maker and that
wants to he knows the in the winter that
in few months he's going to need to
acquire milk not to produce the way the
cream for them for his ice cream but he
doesn't want to be exposed to to the
volatility of any coin so he no one's
know in advance what's going to be the
cost of the milk in three months from
now so for that matter who would want to
write a contract a future contract about
the value of the milk in three months
from now where we would actually need
the milk
to be consumed by him in order to
produce the milk for the for the is I
scream when I say that I'm going to
guarantee you that I buy milk from you
in three months so please give it to me
at a certain price exactly this is
actually the meaning of a future
contract the meaning of the agreement
between the two of us that I might pay
you now a little bit in advance yes it
might be or maybe we just agree and then
you as a producer of milk or as a farmer
you know that you already allocated
certain amount of the or of your a
harvest for this ice cream maker so you
know that you are safe now with the
because you have certain amounts or a
portion of your of your harvest that is
ready to be to be sold and you can take
risks on the red and on the rest of the
of your potential income because you
already have the this contract with me
so this is why derivatives are important
for the creative for the creation of a
healthy economy because both the farmer
and the ice cream maker they know what's
going to be the cost or the revenues for
their businesses and they can allocate
the risk at risk in other parts of their
business on the crypto economy there is
a very big need for the same type of
instruments for engine for instance
let's take the most common example of
hedging if I if you own a certain amount
of of ether for instance you would
probably want to protect the value of
your holdings in case that the ether
would go down and so in that case you
would want to to acquire the type of
contract that would enable the enable
you to sell in up to let's say 10
percent down of the of the current price
in case that the price would go down
another person will say I want to take
the risk because I believe that ether
would go up so I would take your money
now because I believe that anyway I will
not need to buy from you the ether in
the lower price so this is actually what
derivatives are all about in financial
world most of the transactions in the
financial world
derivatives and hedging go hand in hand
and Virginia is one example of a
derivatives one example another example
would be shorts we want to short certain
asset if you believe that the price of
all would go down you can make a short
contract on a short or long according to
your belief on on anything so then all
these examples of derivatives in the
fiat currencies totally it's all
available for you to do today however
you want to do but in cryptocurrencies
not yet available thermal network is
making this available exactly the reason
that they are available in the in the
field wall is that they are centralized
each bank or each financial institution
is writing he's doing the bookmaking of
each one of the contracts or from in
many cases if for every short contract
they have a long contract on the other
side and they know how to measure their
exposure on the crypto world we'd like
to have something that would be a
decentralized solution so there will not
be one institution or one organization
that would handle all the booking and
what shall we do if it will get hacked
so for that matter we would want to have
a solution that would be a decentralized
solution this is what we're building
we're building the infrastructure for a
decentralized solution so that any
financial institution would be able to
issue their derivatives there are
offerings to their customers and we are
in a way an infrastructure company we
sell our product or we provide our
solution to financial institution so
then can any is this mostly used at a
bank or can any even small medium-sized
business use derivatives through thermal
Network the variety of financial
statements can vary from exchanges
probably decentralized exchanges but
maybe later also centralized exchangers
that would like to have an addition to
realize a solution for derivatives but
it could go up to peer to peer lending
insurance companies
a loan institution suit and those
institutions sometimes they become also
there are also players who play in a
more niche type of market so it could be
from very large institutions to a
smaller scale it will not be a single
person doing his business from from home
exchanges and markets and the bigger
players insurance companies it was we
our main target audience target audience
okay
so what's holding back maybe aetherium
or Bitcoin from making something like
this themselves to help with derivative
exchanges I think that the concept
behind most most block chains is to
enable a variety of options for instance
aetherium is built in the concept of the
creation of a very very flexible
platform for the creation of any type of
of contract however if you want to build
a language that is a much safer and much
more and much less exposed to bugs you'd
probably want to develop it in a type of
language that is called formally
verified language these would be the
family of computer languages that would
operate trains planes all kinds of
computer-based machines that you
wouldn't want them to restart so it's it
doesn't really matter it's it's a pain
in the ass if your computer breaks in
the middle of a presentation but it's
not the end of the world but if it
happens to you while you're driving a
train if you're a train driver of you're
flying a plane this is something that is
very very risky so this is the family of
languages that are focused in doing only
what they are meant to do you can do
graphics to them if it was meant to fly
a jet it can go up down right left and
that's pretty much it same thing about
our language on financial instruments
we've built this language that enables
only the creation of financial contracts
so you can do anything out other than
that so in a way those to that
application so the focus of the language
is a completely different from the
concept of a blockchain like aetherium
for instance got it okay so then the
focus of your language thermal network
can be applied to other block chains as
well or or financial institutions have
to use thermo network in order to have
derivatives decentralize the derivatives
themselves actually the solution that we
picked we've built this language which
creates the contract and then we have a
compiler that compiles this contract
into the into each one of the block
chains so at the moment we compile to
EVM which is the theorem and probably it
would also be applied to us and other
block chains we will develop in the
future additional compilers so that
according to develop to the development
of additional block chains in the future
we will develop additional compilers so
that
our partners the financial institution
that we'd like to partner with and they
would be able to offer their goods on
any blockchain that would be relevant so
what are you most looking forward to
with fear mo Network well at the moment
in the middle of our IC o---- so it's a
process that is very very interesting
for us we are looking for partners
design partners and that are interesting
for us to develop and to fine-tune our
product
I couldn't according to the needs of a
variety of all kinds of financial
institution so this is where we are
focused and then what are you most
looking forward to regarding the
application of fear mo network in the
world look where is it going to be most
helpful do you think and that you're
most looking forward to this is a very
good question actually we have a lot of
conversation about this internally and
with our advisers and with the people
that we consult with
some people say that the vast use of of
derivatives in the crypto world would be
hedging others say that it's going to be
swaps I'll just say that is the their
prominently it would be short trotting
and so it varies I can't really say
what's going to be the main one and
hedging and shorting and swaps vo what
via exchanges or via via one where where
will they be able to conduct works we
are not a product that is open for the
for the public so we will develop by the
end of the day we have an API that needs
to be compiled not compiled but it needs
to be used by a financial institution
there's two reasons for that one is that
we believe that for us to be a b2b
company is much more for more relevant
solution in the point that we took the
second thing is that those financial
institutions they are the ones who are
experts in serving customers they know
how to attract they're our customers and
how to serve them with the needs of
theirs and their customers so we would
never want to compete against our
potential customers so our customers are
our partners we would never compete
against them so you do b2b play to
financial institutions and then they
will leverage thermal network for their
clients to be able to do hedges and
swaps yeah exactly it will be for from
their point of view it would be a white
label so it would be their brand that
yes it was all of this amazing stuff and
in a centralized way rather than a
centralized the financial and the
meaning of this centralized manner means
that once they've created a contract a
future the future control for instance
from the example before and it's
actually a token so this token can be
kept for instance within an exchange but
it could be saved on a private wallet it
could be moved from one exchange to
another according to the it's it's
actually an asset like it the same as it
is in the real world if you have a
future contract at the moment you can't
read it just as well you don't need to
wait for the end of the of this contract
it's as value or in during the whole
process of the lifetime of this same
derivative okay and then maybe we also
ask you about let's give another example
because I think examples are really
important so we gave the example about
milk let's say we give another example
maybe we give another relatable example
of how this can be used for maybe the
average person that goes to the
financial institution and wants to do
some hedging or
shorting one very common example would
be example that is very common in the
Fiat world but again doesn't exist in
the crypto wall
let's assume that I believe that certain
asset is going to to be worth much more
than it is to at the moment because the
company I stock of the company but in
the crypto world let's say as I say a
token or our project if I have this
belief I would either acquire this asset
and hope for this to rise or I could say
I would like to take a risk and to to
make a contract with someone else and
saying that if the price would go up two
times then I would get only the de
margin so this is an example of
something that is very common in the
real world in the fiat world but you
can't really do it and yet interesting
ok so that seems to be really important
as in if I thought that somebody that
had at niceö was going to be very
successful or that their token was going
to go up in value already post their IC
o---- that I could then schedule a
derivative with somebody else via smart
contract through thermo Network and then
we could then see what the future holds
and then that way we can do with via the
cryptocurrencies now rather than needing
to do it via fiat currencies that is
correct one thing that needs to be
taking into consideration is that the
creation of the derivatives themselves
needs to be at the moment they are
regulated so the reason that we will
work with they need to be regulated yes
to the creation of those what each one
of those derivatives that they would
like to issue to their customers can you
and I schedule a derivative contract on
thermal network or do we need to still
go through finance when we need to go
through a financial institution that has
the license to issue this
contract so they'll have the license but
then they'll also take a fee as well
right
do I probably want to make a profit from
it okay interesting so okay let's ask
you a couple other questions we like
where where are you from you're from Tel
Aviv from Israel thank you for being
here in San Francisco we we really want
to work more closely with Israel Tel
Aviv we want to work more closely with
China we want to work more closely with
Russia with all these different places
from around the world because it's time
that we all figured out how to
collaborate and work together I can't
agree more I think that being in these
conferences and these events and
speaking to people you find that people
from all over the world they have so
much more alike than they have things
that are not alike yeah surprisingly
enough we all have very strange family
like issues we have lots of people are
setting goals and trying to achieve them
and we all have to eat you know off to
breathe all these interesting things
that bring us actually closer together
this is drew everyone has a dream and
and he meets people in the way to to
fulfill his dream and it's very a warm
feeling to feel that you have people who
have the same dream as you yes similar
so let's ask them this question because
it seems to be more and more pressing as
we go throughout civilization it seems
as though exponential technology is
making the rich people very very rich
and making poor people just slightly
more wealthy over time what do you think
is gonna happen to that wealth
inequality how do you think we can maybe
solve that this is a very good question
I think that the having different too
much difference between the quality of
lives of people anywhere within any
society and between societies is
something that causes lots of tension
yes and this tension
always leads to something bad so it's
either jealousy which is the smaller
scale of tension or much worse event
that happened between societies and
between groups of people that starts
hating each other or starts yeah I think
once against the others and so I think
in order to have a very healthy society
we needs to make sure we need to make
sure that not everyone will have the
same it's not the Communists for
perception but you need to have up to a
certain amount of difference you need
that the poor would a very good life you
know still and the and model that they
would they have the opportunity a real
opportunity to be in any type of field
control eyes themselves they have enough
opportunity to find what they are
passionate about they have enough access
to opportunity in a way you would want a
child that to have the same
opportunities or regardless if he is
born to a poor family or a rich family
you need to have the mining opportunity
and the moment the world is not yet
there not yet there so maybe then a good
goal for our for the wealth inequality
then is to have every child wherever
they're born in the world have equal
access to opportunity to actualize
themselves into the world and then from
there then continue incentivizing
innovation as well so that people that
do innovate that they can still become
quite successful monetarily in the world
as well yeah I can't agree more I think
that it's also in the matter of there's
a need for those who are lucky ones who
are lucky enough to be in the in the
phase word they are very successful also
to have a look on those who aren't yeah
we have a lot here in San Francisco big
difference in well some of them do that
you have in Israel like very big
difference here it's about one mile away
or like one and a half kilometers away
from very very wealthy very very poor is
that about like do you have something
very close like that in Israel
we we do but not in the scale of in the
States I think the I can in general if I
will generalize that it's still less
extreme the difference between classes
but it's getting wider and wider in the
past few years I've seen this is not a
good phenomena I've seen some of the
technology advances and telev even it's
like crazy beautiful buildings and
beautiful technology that's being made
by very smart people and I can say that
I can see that that's somewhat similar
to San Francisco as well so then there
are people that are like still have much
less so what do we do about that
we asked like we like to ask that
question why on the show another
question we like to ask on the shows do
you think we're alone in the cosmos wow
I I wish I had the answer I really don't
know I wish we aren't why because you
want to have multiple opportunities and
multiple opportunities means not to be
binded only by the how much how many are
we are now eight billion you want to
have another eight billion that have
completely different perception yeah
everything about and it'd be so cool
like learning another planets history
yeah yeah so ok and then do you think
that we are in a simulation I'm not sure
if I understand do you think there's a
designer to the world that we live in I
if the question means that I believe in
God and no I believe in people and then
do you think that there was something
that made people nature and do you think
there is do you think there was
something at the very beginning of
nature and science that made the code
for the nature in science I wish I knew
enough about it but I believe there
wasn't any act of creation but some God
or brought some by some I don't know
three wolves that carry the world under
and
back or whatever to fairytales that
someone and just made up so then what do
you think's the most beautiful thing in
the world
the future why um because it's it has
all the possibilities the present and
the past don't have any possibilities
well they have somewhere they put in
their interpretation but there have
already happened and the future is full
of possibilities full of Dreams full of
things that needs to be accomplished so
this is the most beautiful thing
thank you so much for coming on the show
thank you you are a pleasure I'm really
excited to see pheromone Network take
off and continue helping people with
derivatives especially on the new
blockchain infrastructure that we're
building into our world financial
institutions be ready everyone
we're coming yes if you guys had a good
time watching please and check out the
links in the bio it's a fear Mon Network
tell two people about this they'll tell
two people and we'll continue spreading
the word subscribe comment below give us
a like share it with other people go
make a video about it go write about it
don't just consume go create with this
content as well join us on patreon so we
continue doing cool things like coming
to blockchain economic forum and talking
to smart people and sharing the content
with you thanks everyone for tuning in
peace thank you bye bye